Interviewer: What is the biggest challenge
in transitioning from your physics career
to your science educational efforts?
Quinn: Well, I guess the biggest challenge
was giving up my physics career.
I was about to retire, and I wanted to retire
for various reasons.
But most physicists go on doing physics
research, particularly theorists like me who
don't need any equipment to do it.
However, I was committing myself to a project
that would take a year and a half, full-time
work, to chair the committee that developed
the framework for K-12 science education.
And it was a choice: Do I take this one on
or do I continue doing my physics?
And I thought, well I could write a few more
physics papers that would be read by a few
people, but if we really could do something
that improved science education nationally,
that would be a worthwhile effort.
So I decided to stop doing physics and start
doing education work.